Europe's farming industry is set to get
a big boost after the European Union's
and main institutions reached agreement
on long-awaited reforms to the Common
Agricultural Policy or camp after
marathon talks in Luxembourg in Brussels
under the stewardship of the Irish
presidency the institution's seal the
deal on reform of the four main pillars
of the cafe which makes up the biggest
slice at the EU budget this is the first
time that there's been a co decision
function for the Parliament it's the
first time that we've had 27 soon-to-be
28 member states involved so there has
been a really challenging job
politically to do to find a way of
finding compromises finding a way
forward how we distribute money amongst
farmers very political and very
controversial I think we've come to an
acceptable compromise now that makes
sense that give countries that have
different structures and different
priorities different options while at
the same time keeping a common policy
intact the reforms were agreed after
some 18 months of negotiations capped by
four days of intensive talks they're
aimed at guaranteeing good living
standards for farmers and providing
predictable food supplies at fair prices
to consumers the package will regulate
the way farm subsidies are paid improve
the efficiency of the market in
agricultural products help foster rural
development and set out rules for cap
management and control it's been waited
to discriminate positively in favour of
young farmers and will result in a
greening of the policy by encouraging
sustainable development the task of
implementing these wide-reaching reforms
now falls to the incoming lithuanian
presidency